we're back in New York after a big day
on Capitol Hill big night for president
Trump addressing the nation and a deeply
divided Congress about the state of our
union it was an inspiring speech filled
with emotional moments honoring heroes
America's fallen freedom fighters and
more he made a call for bipartisan unity
that was met at times with resistance
from many Democrats in the room we're
going to break all that down for you
throughout the hour but we begin with
the president's tributes a patriotism
and the American people the United
States is a compassionate nation we are
proud that we do more than any other
country anywhere in the world to help
the needy the struggling and the
underprivileged I am extending an open
hand
to work with members of both parties
Democrats and Republicans to protect our
citizens of every background color
religion and Creed my duty and the
sacred duty of every elected official in
this chamber is to defend Americans to
protect their safety their families
their communities and their right to the
American dream because Americans are
dreamers to here tonight is Preston
shock a twelve-year-old boy from Redding
California who noticed that veterans
graves were not marked with flags on
Veterans Day he decided
role by himself to change that and
started a movement that has now placed
40,000 flags at the graves of our great
heroes Preston's reverence for those who
have served our nation reminds us of why
we salute our flag why we put our hands
on our hearts for the pledge of
allegiance and why we proudly stand for
the national anthem
freedom stands tall over one more
monument
this one this capital this living
monument this is the monument to the
American people
all right well as much as it pains me to
do this I have to give you credit Gregg
he used the line that you've said on the
five before Americans or dreamers - yes
we'd like to get your reaction to that
first I saw that I was on the train
slightly tipsy I might add a yell got
smart that's fine and then they escorted
me out and put placed me an L in a
contact hold but no that was you know
that was I was waiting for somebody to
actually steal that line for me but I
mean overall I thought the speech wasn't
can I hate the word conciliatory because
I can barely say it too many C's in that
word I thought it was more like a double
down on his vision that it didn't it
seemed like it was a vision was directed
at Americas at Americans and not at
anybody else and I think I was wrong
because on the show last night I said
you should keep it short short and sweet
and say he's never gonna do it again he
did the exact opposite
he was neck is it he went very long fare
like a 90 minutes and I think it's
because it wasn't for me it was for
people who had eight years in the desert
and could use 90 minutes in the Oasis
and so it's like you've heard enough it
got felt you can complain all you want
this isn't for you this is for Americans
who want to hear directly from their
president about why it's okay to feel
good right and I think a lot of people
did feel good about it judging by the
reaction Dana what did you think I liked
how at the end he focused the speech on
the people of this he started this you
know it was a nice sandwich she started
it being this is not about me it was
about you the American people and he
ends it that way he's a very optimistic
person right so he believes that America
can get the job done and that was what
that was really all about last night
he's the head coach for capitalism he's
like walk tickin through all the
economic headlines and we're gonna talk
a little bit more about that it was to
me it was a bit of a laundry list but
that's how these things are I don't see
how much follow-through there is on some
of the policy items that you typically
see in a State of the Union which lays
out an agenda so that the president can
hit the road and keep selling something
that he wants to try to pass this year
that was it wasn't that kind of a speech
but certainly the people who watched it
felt good about it but if you're a
Democrat and you watched it you didn't
but about it just like as Republicans
watching President Obama didn't feel
good about his it's almost the mirror
image of the last eight years yet yes
but I thought he did make a few
overtures to the Democrats but it's
almost like they didn't see it maybe
because they didn't want to see it
Kimberly well that was the part that we
were talking about earlier we were kind
of reviewing it where you saw that he
was talking about employment numbers and
everything in the black community and
you were looking basically the
Congressional Black Caucus didn't
acknowledge it or clap or anything like
that so of course there's gonna be some
partisan reaction that you're gonna see
manifest itself
not happy but overall I thought that
there was a lot in this speech that was
great for you know both sides whether
they were a Democrat or whether you were
a Republican I think it was a very
uplifting speech in about America in my
opinion United not divided and he
certainly had a lot of tremendous
material to work with in terms of the
accomplishments that he's been able to
make as relates to the economy and
national security and my favorite part
by the way were the personal stories
that really resonated I agree I think
that was the best part one did you have
a favorite part can you name one thing
you liked about it one thing I liked
about it besides the end that was it it
took a long time to get to the good part
which was the end ya know I thought you
know what I like I expected that it was
gonna be conciliatory to quote Greg I
thought it was gonna be that he was
extending the olive branch saying you
know what it's time for unity in a
divided country and he just didn't do it
he just disappointed me I always think
you know what Donald Trump is going to
become presidential at this moment he's
finally gonna put on the jacket and act
like the president and he always let you
know I'm like Charlie Brown on the
football with this guy because yesterday
what did he do instead of offering to
unify the country he doubles down on all
of his talking points that almost the
talking points are about unity no it was
another battle as Americans I mean it is
he a point know even if it was about
Americans it would be about all America
instead like he's doing he leave out
well I say let's take something like
that was so dramatic which is what he
said about immigrants right and he held
he has a family there are black family
whose children I think
children were killed rights by members
of ms-13 and these people are crying
they're a motive it was a little bit
lower boy you know he had several people
who were buying and upset he used that
quite strategically okay as a dramatic
reality show type of thing no one's ever
done that right well I didn't think I
don't know if it's appropriate but I'll
leave that to the audience to judge it
might be effective president doesn't for
go ahead okay
but then you stop and you think wait a
minute he's demonizing all illegal
immigrants as if they're members of MSC
I think you're conflating it and the
American did not let's play some of that
Olive Branch right now when he's talking
about infrastructure go ahead America is
a nation of builders we built the Empire
State Building in just one year isn't it
a disgrace that it can now take ten
years just to get a minor permit
approved for the building of a simple
Road I am asking both parties to come
together to give us safe fast reliable
and modern infrastructure that our
economy needs and our people deserve so
that's a major component of this 2018
agenda Greg and we believe the Democrats
would get on board since they've been
pushing for new infrastructure spending
for the last eight years yeah that's why
it's like I think that Democrats have to
give them something there if people like
me are aren't crazy about it like III
here infrastructure and I hear tons and
tons and tons of spending that ends up
not at infrastructure it always goes
somewhere else so if I'm unhappy with it
at least the Democrats should be happy
because I feel like I'm losing something
and speaking of just the Democrats can
we just talk briefly about that richie
cunningham hologram oh you know joe
kennedy jr. yeah yeah we're I mean if
you want to talk about leadership
compared to trump that was a student
council president where was Potsie and
Ralph Malph
and the guy had enough chapstick on his
face to cover the entire Olympic bobsled
team I do want to get your quick
reaction on aka Potsie and then I want
to play another quick sound bite of the
president saying he wants to reopen
Gitmo so let's listen
to the ghetto first and then you can
take on Potsie it's Ritchie terrorists
who do things like place bombs and
civilian hospitals are evil when
possible we have no choice but to
annihilate them when necessary we must
be able to detain and question them but
we must be clear terrorists are not
merely criminals they are unlawful enemy
combatants that's significant
I've always been for keeping Gitmo open
and for what the purpose of it which was
to hold enemy combatants and to be able
to question them and there's all there's
been this constant tension of should you
bring them to the United States where
they would get all the due process
afforded to people who are in the United
States and I think the answer to that
should be no al-baghdadi was a prisoner
at Gitmo
he was released where did we catch him
again no he's out there committing
terrorist acts so um but again that's
another point that that is something you
don't actually have to have in this
speech in an hour and 28 minutes speech
or 20 minute speech you could have quite
left that one out but it was used to
needle on the other side and so there's
lots of things you could add in or or
not um I will say about Joe Kennedy I
think people are being really mean like
you or being mean nobody mean like I
don't like to go after somebody but I
didn't like it when they went after
Jindal or Marco Rubio or anybody who
does these responses it's a miserable
thing I actually think though that the
Democrats had to be fairly happy with
that are they working on a car behind
him okay and there's a whole thing about
that whole thing about like the sins of
the funcle' twice-removed or something
but if you're a young Democrat and you
feel like you cannot stand President
Trump and you saw that and you're like
there's hope for us it's not Bernie
Sanders it's not Elizabeth Warren I'm
not saying that Joe Kennedy is gonna run
in 2020 but it was definitely a contrast
and but it's still the Kennedys it's
still another family it's still like
having the Clintons just you're just
drawing from the same families that like
having the Trump's having this is why
no no no no no miss my point why listen
listen I'm talking about political
dynasties Trump's not a political
dynasty Kennedys are burns he has his
daughter he has your complete with
anyway missing my point on purpose you
think okay yes structure okay I'm dense
in relevant to infrastructure let me
just say the man laid out no plan he
didn't say I'm gonna find money here I'm
gonna provide money here he passed the
tax what you should like it that is that
well no a Democrat so no I think that
you should if you're saying let's work
on this infrastructure let's Democrats
you want to do it let's get to it
Chuck Schumer had an op-ed in The
Washington Post yesterday saying this
guy is talking about private fees maybe
even raising gas taxes Americans aren't
going to respond well to that rural
community is going to be left out I
agree with you where is Trump on that
and when it comes to something like this
business about Americans or dreamers to
how can you not see that as somehow
making it is if you or you are the equal
of a child that was brought here without
any volition on their part and their
part you are brought here is a child and
is seeking the opportunity to fulfill
their American dream I wait a second
there more so there they are more
special not an American here I'm a dream
why can't I be a dreamer I dream every
day I see the lights yeah I'll see the
light in your eyes yeah it's kind of
sexy cute this is this is more and more
this is how Trump distorts things and
then it gets heard by some people as oh
wow so patriotic so wonderful in fact
what he's doing is putting down people
and hurting is the point of that line
was that it has a double meaning and it
was meant to do exactly what's happening
at this table
no it's caught it just exposes
confirmation bias you're hearing what
you want to hear how did you see
personal stories that all Americans can
relate to and was more message of
unification I didn't see in any way that
he was trying to be a divisive he's
saying that we can all grow and prosper
together as a country especially if we
work cooperatively to achieve those ends
for example like we've done with the
economy all right and also I think it's
onion turn
that it's strange to a lot of people
that's the tragedy is that we think this
is a weird idea that we're all Americans
so that we're all dreamers and that
people think that's weird
that's sad oh no you never heard morning
in America huh yeah that's been around
guess what this optimism in around the
problem is Donald Trump is speaking in a
way that keeps putting down people and
you don't hear it no I think you're
reading minds open you're not hearing
people down he's lifting people all
right we're going to